- JOHNNY.
OKAY, CARTER.
I CAN STAY HERE
ALL NIGHT.
SO WHY DON'T
YOU AND I CUT THE CRAP,
AND YOU TELL ME WHAT HAPPENED
ON MARCH 15TH?
- AND WHAT'S IN IT
FOR CARTER FINLEY?
- WHAT'S IN IT
FOR YOU
IS I DON'T SEND YOU BACK
TO JAIL.
- [sighs]
THE GUY'S NAME
IS CAT BRANCHMAN.
I MET HIM DOWNTOWN AT A CLUB
CALLED "THE CLUTCHING KITTEN."
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
OF IT.
IT'S DOWN ON THE CORNER
OF HANG AND FUR STREET.
- CAT BRANCHMAN.
SO WHAT'S A GUY
LIKE YOU
AND A GUY NAMED CAT--
[sighs]
OKAY.
I KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE DOIN', FINLEY.
YOU'RE JUST USING WHAT YOU SEE
IN MY POSTER.
- I'M NOT, DETECTIVE.
I'M TELLING THE TRUTH.
- WE'LL SEE HOW MUCH TRUTH
YOU TELL
AFTER A FEW WEEKS
IN SOLITARY CONFINE--
- FINE, DETECTIVE.
YOU'VE TWISTED MY ARM.
- NOW, THAT'S BETTER.
- THE GUY'S NAME WASN'T
CAT BRANCHMAN.
- THANK YOU.
- IT WAS A CHINESE GUY NAMED
"MR. MEOW."
HE'S THE REAL
GANG BOSS.
STORY WENT HE HUNG GUYS
FROM TREES
AND TOOK PICTURES
OF THEM.
- FINLEY.
- USED TO RUN A CLUB DOWNTOWN.
A FRONT, OF COURSE.
CALLED IT "THE PAW AND POSTER."
- FINLEY.
- RAN IT WITH A GUY NAMED
"HONG IN THAR."
- OKAY.
LET'S TRY THIS
ONE MORE TIME.
FINLEY?
WHO DO YOU WORK FOR?
- UM...
COFFEE.
MR. COFFEE COOP.
- YOU--COFFEE COOP?
- HIS NAME WAS
"BALDY TALL MAN COFFEE COOP."
- [sighs]
NOW YOU'RE JUST TALKING
ABOUT ME.
FINLEY, I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
ONE MORE CHANCE.
WHO IS IN CHARGE?
- HIS NAME WAS
"ANGRY MAN."
- [sighs]
- THE WAREHOUSE IS LOCATED
IN THE DIPLOMA
FOR BEING A DETECTIVE.
- I WANT A NAME.
- JUSTIN.
- THANK YOU.
- HANGTREE--
- DON'T SAY "HANG."
GOD DAMN IT,
DO NOT SAY "HANG."
- HANG--
- NOPE.
- HANGMAN JUSTIN CATS...
- FINLEY.
- POSTER.
- DO NOT SAY "POSTER" OR "CAT."
- CAT POSTER.
- OKAY, THAT'S IT.
I'M LOSING MY PATIENCE.
WINSLOW, GET THIS MORON
OUTTA HERE.
- [sighs]
- I'M LOSING MY PATIENCE.
LET'S TRY THIS
ONE MORE TIME.
I'M GETTIN TOO OLD
FOR THIS [bleep].
[groans]
- WELL-PLAYED, DETECTIVE.
WELL-PLAYED, INDEED.
- HEY, CARTER.
YOU HANG IN THERE.